young jt brubacher
looking for his first big league wins 11
innings pitched
and he comes through with a strikeout
mira is gone
two outs corbin burns third start for
corbin and no record 3.00 earned run
average
here's the pitch
and gonzales a fly ball to right hit
pretty well going back
to the wall it's off the top of the wall
and gonzo into second base with a
stand-up double
got the ball in the air you love to see
him get the ball in the air which means
you like to see him take shots the other
direction much as you hit the ball in
the air that way
and
all that mixed with the kind of power he
has
means you can get moments like this
where he comes within a foot of a home
run
pirates bats
pick up right where they left off out to
right
underneath the glove of hiro and
gonzalez is gonna score
and the pirates two batters in have a
one-nothing lead
that's just a good execution there from
adam frazier
one out with jarrod dyson at the plate
and he hits it past short
dyson drives in the run pirates up
two-nothing
let's get everybody involved everybody
[Applause]
it seemed like everybody was struggling
at the same time and everybody's
swinging the bat better at the same time
that's 98 running away and
not trying to do too much just slapping
it the other way
zooming in a fly ball and right to the
first inning getting third in the order
for the first time in his career
and a swing and a miss two up two down
in the third
first two innings he had to use a lot of
pitches
not exactly where he wanted it but yeah
the results were pretty good kind of a
backup slider that could take the air
out of it yeah i mean not only
physically but mentally there you go two
seamer will in the inning a strikeout of
cole tucker as burns retires the side
brewers coming up in the fourth
smoke who lined out the center in the
first inning shift his own for the
brewers first baseman
and that's in the air in the right
center field he hit that well that's
going to get to the gap jarrod dyson
runs it down here is going to tear
around third he's coming around gonzalez
with the relay to the plate not in time
and the brewers are on the board
just in smoke with a double to the gap
and it's a two to one ball game yeah
just like that single double boy smoke
put a charge into that one that's why he
doesn't bunt i was wondering why he
doesn't bun that's why
put one to the gap and up against a wall
there's a fastball
two-two pitch and did he go around they
appeal to first he did not
at the curveball from burns and now the
count's full of three balls and two
strikes
and now
we got it out at second base
polanco drifted off the bag
and orlando rc ended up with a baseball
on a throw
from narvaez and it was almost like a
collision as arcia caught the ball as
polanco was trying to get back into
second base as omar narvaez comes to the
plate looking to snap out of an 0 for 19
10 pitch that is pulled down the right
field line and it is going to be off the
top of the wall tucker will play it off
the wall
around third azurius he will score
and it's a long rbi single for omar
narvaez he was just a foot or two away
from hitting his first home run in a
brewers uniform but the brewers have
tied it at two
so runner at first and smoke at the
plate smoke drove in the
run back in the fourth inning for the
crew
trying to break this tie in the sixth
and smoke goes the other way he hit it
well reynolds going back and that is off
the foul pole it's gone
justin smoke
going the other way with a two-run shot
as the brewers take the lead
he does that a lot with a breaking pitch
a curveball that hung up in his eyes and
went right with it
there's your lead right
and brew is able to take the lead
so reynolds at the plate overshift on
the right side freddie peralta
here's the 1-0
sharply hit past the diving
second baseman hera into right field
brian reynolds brings home riddle the
pirates down one here in the sixth
turley the 2-1
high chop coming toward
now the baseball is the third baseman
riddle whose throw is
in time to get him in the nice stretch
by osuna
jt riddle that ball died on the grass
had to come in in a hurry bare hand and
throw and ossuna the big stretch marie
polanco who has singled and walked
coming off of a home run in a double
yesterday
admires this one wow he does it
polanco puts the bucks in front with a
two run home run in the egg that feels
so good for gregory polanco
wow a moon shot
gregory polanco just an absolute moon
shot
a no doubter
five four buckos on the polanco go ahead
home run
out to left
reynolds has it and the buccos sweep the
brewers
[Applause]